tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj ed egizio tornati su
melo è la cosa che strana dall'ultimo
episodio che non so perché la scritta è
capovolta e la cosa è parecchio strana
comunque a heinola l'ultimo fa avevo
giocato chi cazzo è successo non era
così a scelta il tavolino il tavolino
che genchi era posseduto me lo ricordavo
la ragazza aspettati un numero 9
successi bending han han ring inform
caso che cazzo è successo perché altri
ragazzi e sono passati dieci secondi
dall'inizio nel video mi sono preso un
infarto non è normale da allora calmi
calca nice dh tranquilli iniziamo questo
video perché no era tutti ragazzi e
benvenute questo nuovo video sono un po
vj ed oggi siamo super parate è un gioco
tranquillo e andiamo su aino se non
sbaglio che adesso la scritta ok
non siamo neanche bambini
ma deve rompere il cazzo te l'hanno già
nell'ultimo milioni non andava bene
e cade anche il testo
come se non bastano e il vino quello
cammino connette lo specchio del mondo
madonna era ubriaco forte con distinto
st cagata dunque dato che mi squilla il
telefono a caso corrispondere buongiorno
margherita formaggio in diavola grazie
mille ordinato mezzo la fase già in
ritardo
l'altro non mi risponde poi ovviamente
non mi gaga e poi chiami karaianni mi
faccio a sprecare tanto di quel crane
torna nonna devi fare un debito a vita
con la vodafone e loro clienti è che chi
vuoi che sia uno che non risponde che
rompe i [ __ ] magari si spegne il
telefono non venire non deve rompere il
cazzo fino alla morte
non c'è c'è verso acari ancora coastal
cari ragazzi non ha senso va beh e poi
diventa buio a caso and 1 e la calotta
cosa ecco i'm coming to see you non era
così ci sono tre volte ragazzi la porta
che fu
io vado ad aprire anche se so già chi è
il pezzo di [ __ ] della scorsa volta che
eccolo lì lo sapevo sentite l'ultima
volta l'ho rimorchiata come si deve
essere riusciti a finirlo
incredibilmente però stavolta devo
provare a fare una cosa diversa è la
solita prova a fare controlla la stanza
o su muovermi proprio tranquillamente
cioè quella si muove per casa così
madonna quanto sei bella mimì sta
mettendo paura state allora noi ci
mettiamo qui tranquilli e leggiamo per
lui da [ __ ] che non sei altro perché
devi correre finale ma [ __ ] corda
quanto mi ha decapitato con uno schiaffo
ed è per questo ragazzi che non dovete
mai far incazzare le donne quando hanno
il loro periodo perché solo sono
alquanto violente tra l'altro credo che
il sangue nella stanza sia proprio
quello che penso io comunque di nuovo e
più sostanza di merda
le notizie del giorno l'altro giorno una
donna stava stava andando in macchina ed
è ed è stata ferita gravemente ed è
morta stamattina a ok
credo che sia effettivamente lei e della
news dell'ultimo mese
kind sei le news nell'ultimo mese prima
va a controllare la stanza ma cercare di
fare qualcosa nel frattempo si può
leggere libri oppure calciare le sedi
anche io vado a dormiva ya a dormire il
telefono telefono e sparito perché a
carico un team a chiamare la sto
chiamando io pronto sente dove cazzo
sparita tra l'altro pronto a acari
ascolta io non sono morto non ancora
sono vivo e un futuro non ascolta non
dire ste cazzate perché già prima si è
vinto male io ti amo non vuoi lasciare
la tua anima tranquilla adesso te l'ho
detto io che sei un deficiente poi fai
quello che vuoi
ron gambe numero numero sbagliato per us
donna hanno capito se ma chi è questa
c'è n'è una che nessuno al telefono però
hanno capito chi è
c'è una che si è appena penso sia lei a
cari e lo sa cari ascolta io non sono
morto sono ci mette un pochettino male
capisco le cose ovviamente è la
telefonata di prima questa è l'altra
parte del telefono
cosa intendi c print e la sto chiamando
dall inferno poche parole qua dovrei
aver ritirato lo schiaffo effettivamente
ma non sono stato io giuro ragazzi mi si
sta incamminando il cervello era aria al
contrario fantastico praticamente cosa
ci sono le scritte al contrario comando
lei non lui è una cosa strana è come se
io praticamente fosse nell'aldilà con
lei e quindi leggessi le cose al
contrario mentre con lui sono ancora nel
mondo reale c'è un casino un po parole
ce l'avete un orologio nella stanza e
forniamo sai tu porca [ __ ] la tua
stanza
almeno questo posso andare a dormire si
può andare a dormire anche fantastico
nell'inferno si può dormire
credo che sia inferno perché c'è scritto
nel titolo del gioco però già slightly
morning ok
già lo sapevo ragazzi gioite perché c'è
mediaset premium all'inferno che questa
terna la tv inception fatemi leggere
so che domani al nostro anniversario ok
sì ma non ti incazzare ma non posso
certamente andare dove voglio non lo
capisci questo non lo capisco non
capisco niente
ho detto che non ho mai non ho mai
mancato uno prima quindi non mi dispiace
che stronzo di merda però e non è stato
divertente questo è quello che gli ha
detto e allora te lo meriti uno schiaffo
stronzo di merda
a parte gli scherzi credo che la storia
si sa che lei durante l'anniversario è
morta in un incidente stradale nelle
ultime parole di lui sono state quelle
brutte di prima comunque va beh eccomi
mike mi mancava giochi mi mancava il
telefono la chiamata la chiamata che ho
ricevute da latte vero abbastanza per
oggi lo stai facendo nulla di buono per
noi è di 26 a lending senza fine da
piano sta mandando avanti ragazzi anche
se è difficile c'era scampo accesso e
sono più che altro
avg è la cassa 4 fa vigenti
pensi che hanno anche il coraggio di
chiamare cosa ti spunti cosa che spunti
sono hai rotto il cazzo gonna a sia
aperto il libro giustamente si è aperto
lì no perché prima idea far prendere gli
infarti e poi si aprono i libri giusto
famiglia agosto 9 ma la voce stesse cose
sì sì che poi è andata al viaggio di
lavoro è l'anniversario già le stesse
cose
il diario finisce qui uguale all'altro
praticamente scusami kazuki scusami si
scusa una vicenda però non si capiscono
perché sono morti c'è una è morta
l'altro no comunque anche se decapiti la
gente a caso non è proprio diario del
cuore come mamma va bene un importante
ormai ginocchio porco fatto cosa vuoi da
me kazuki non lo so adesso mi dice che
mi viene a trovare
ci vediamo domani kazuki ma i ragazzi se
tutte come l'altra volta adesso le
bestie compare in camera
il lupo infatti ha bussato mi sembrava
strano
adesso vediamo se lui è un gran pezzo di
figo come lei e kazuki fermati ma lui a
lui non si ferma amico che lo scooter a
lui lui stupro a caso la ragazza sarà
fermata un'altra volta acari sei tu a
chiari prendi la mia mano vieni veloce
cosa kazuki dove sei
ragazzi ho capito domanda ecco l'accordo
l'ho visto qui che grava è ok non la
voce avevo messo ci ho messo mezz'ora
se tu kazuki ok cece fra il premi la
mano prendi amano velocemente prima che
katy stuprino and 28 another love her un
altro amore è una cosa lo ritaglia
questa cosa devo dargli una mano dal
basso cammino qui ecco cos'altro non ho
capito ma bellissimo lo peso ragazzino
ci sto capendo un caso delle partenze
oggi sto capendo più niente
ok questa è la gnocca e ci risiamo di
nuovo per la 400esima volta check del
rom
ok l'ho sentita gridare quell'urlo a
chiarire se tu ok adesso so cosa fare
non devo dargli una mano attraverso il
camino sei tu a cari da lì la mano dalla
mano ok adesso lo so perché l'ho visto
prima e adesso a farci ok ho dato la
mano sei tu kazuki ho detto velocemente
vai adesso dovrebbe vedersi chiuso sì sì
ce l'ho fatta
non ti lascerò andare sono lì si sono
riuniti usciamo di qui i ragazzi si sono
riuniti non ci posso credere bellissimo
ok ok dai usciamo dai veloci beh ce l'ho
fatta fanta sucate anzi quando ho
sentito urlare a carilo distrattamente
raggiunta per salvare una carica non
esisteva la ragazza che sto tenendo per
mano ad esse la vera cari questa domanda
non sembra avere risposta
e non importa
ma tu sondelli si sono trovati anche
loro ragazzi sono diventato il nuovo
cupido perché con me si innamora la
gente a caso allora è durato due episodi
ma l'ho amato tantissime bellissimo che
poi è anche profondo come gioco quindi
mi piace un casino
non mi aspettavo non mi aspettavo questo
finale ve lo dico assolutamente a true
and mirrors ed lovers quindi il finale è
vero è che un plesso ragazzi dire che
posso concludere qui e non ho parole
perché secondo me il creatore di mad
padre di questo che lo stesso è un genio
[ __ ] genio perché non è possibile che
crea de sti cosi fantastici comunque
regalerà dal secolo che non provavo a
fare un gioco del genere sono
contentissimo di averlo di fatto niente
ragazzini che posso concludere qui se
volete che ne facciano altri di questo
genere di teme nome quindi niente
ragazzi dire che posso concludere qui
come al solito ragazzi servizio vi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come
ogni video tratta nella descrizione sede
tenevano i siti iscrivetevi le ci
vedevano prossimo video è la ragazzi